discovering enterprise data sources is a
time-consuming challenge and is usually
based on tribal knowledge data discovery
is now made simple with data catalog
[Music]
data catalog is a fully managed and
scalable data discovery a metadata
management service that empowers
organizations to quickly discover
understand and manage all their data in
Google Cloud I am Anita keeping Gucci
and today we'll be tackling data
discovery with data catalog data
discovery usually starts with a question
what's the slowest link in our supply
chain how many of our retail customers
are within driving distance to our
competitors new flagship we're a demonic
butterfly stop during that annual
migration unfortunately users spend an
incredible amount of time and effort
discovering validating and getting
access to the correct data sets and
sources and to be able to answer their
questions but thanks to the same
technology that powers Gmail and drive
data catalog provides a simple and easy
to use user interface with powerful
structured search capabilities to
quickly and easily find data assets so
now let's see it in action using the
search bar at the top of data catalog
you can conduct a search of all your
data assets across bigquery and cloud
pub/sub we'll be adding additional data
sources in the future including on-prem
data catalog also provides faceted
search allowing users to search by type
column and tag across literally millions
of data assets beyond the search bar you
can view popular tables which span the
most queried and viewed bakery tables in
the past 30 days you can also explore
pub sub topics as well as tables and
views and actually get started with
creating tag templates the beauty of
data catalog is that it has built-in
access level controls which Onis
ossicles
allowing users to get started with data
exploration in a seamless and more
secure way thank you so much for
watching and please check out our data
catalog videos or visit our website to
learn more
you